buona salute di ragazze benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo bisogno di it takes
dove siamo io e ciccio marino in una
nuova avventura in critica e buona
visione
allora devi andare dall'altra parte e io
ti spacco qua e tu salti capito cosa
c'erano dall'alta aspetta dai corvi però
ho anche ballo che è più attaccato
chiodo bruna letta che funzionò va beh
incredibile no bellissimo per l'idea
cacchio ma è parte loro dispiace mi vedo
meglio per avere sempre e se faccio
questa prova a inchiodarmi aia porco
demonio ha tanto me lo devo togliere mi
ha incastrati ha fatto malissimo quale
visto raitre padova hanno li devono
toglierlo io ma come faccio se non
troppo distante a meno che non faccio lo
riguarda così l'ho tolta l'ho tolto ce
l'ho tolto dondolando li aspetta mi sa
che devi aspettare che facciamo cosa io
di qua ma spara spara col chiodo qua
dove qui tipo anno guarda e ha davvero
perfetto permetto ma chi si cioè
fainardi ho trovato di noi ragazzi
questa dinamica si continua così è
fantastica tratta roma è incredibile ma
che non lo so ma è geniale ok questa
bellissima tra l'altro chiodo top è che
devo fare cartone solo punto evo chiodo
dopo al suolo quindi vedo pare io caso
puoi fare due cose allora siccome così
gialli vanno colpiti però non con che
contesta acqua aspettato
corri sta martellando di bestia muoverci
mi sa che non tiene moltissimo cosi fino
alla fine in fondo li chiamo io
anche perché su quel fischio di new york
ma è che io ho rotto tante di quelle
borghesie momento alpone rial
achievement che diventa tinte del
sottotitolo incredibile pazzesco sì sì
dopo la prima rock ha aggiunto capisco
ok il resto salve
basta lillo l'inno ma poi il libro
dell'amore fatti che oggi ho capito già
ma ndo è una roba è una roba madonna di
vista mi sembra lite di planners la cosa
brutta è quello che atri blocca l'affare
pestelli perfetto sblocco l'altro bike
ei buyer molla lo è ora
esatto ha però mai è certo ma è normale
ce l'ho fatta questa qua è veramente un
case a quale di bella la ruota non solo
predicato ok allora 1x2
ok let's golf penso a fare una sfida
misti giochi in d2 devi fare ma è ma
capite deve essere una cosa pazzesca ci
sono comunque fatto arriva arriva dove
c'era un posto su dove lo vedo lo so 36
però non devi andare sennò un povero no
mi sa che coronato nel gioco però robe
insieme non ha capito cosa perché mamma
del doj poi c'è un'altra roba
eccola arco diffondere yes wilde che si
formerà sopra devo fare qualcosa io tuo
occhio che l'ultimo chiodo quindi
qualcosa così aspetto che tengo fermo
se c'è questa roba pro ballo ballo ballo
ballo ballo ma dopotutto lo giuro di
ballo aspetta ecco ma meno male che
volete fare adesso devi fare quella roba
li madou del casinò niente lo sta
vedendo dato a visuale perché mi
dimentico sempre guardata tra virtuale
ma si può guardare
ho messo ora devi staccare quello in
fondo no ormai fatta cadere tu devi
attrattiva nei subito che lo so perché
sono va da nessuna parte
bravissimo brother ora devo fare è
proprio ci arrivo anno con il fianco di
fianco che oggi per qua no no no no sono
fatto male
esatto quello quello che sei quello che
sei puntando ciba se no qui in basso a
sinistra
questo qua esatto e poi devi esatto
quello e poi quello sopra questo prima
sopra il mezzo prima e questo no questo
ok perfetto
ora puoi fare è quello di campo o di
quello giu ma dov'era casalino e
pazienti sempre fisso ce l'ho fatta
incredibile che ho messo sei ore ma ma è
bellina e proprio veramente sisifo
ubriacone ok ci sono scandali sotto
tantissimo che dobbiamo fare ok
by yes era questa due ore per arriverà
una cassetta degli attrezzi alla fine
magari con questo tipo fatti accordi del
mondo lo sa dice che un bosco e questo
mini boss si sono resi tali rifiuti o di
in faccia
provaci che si è imposto incredibile non
basta secondo il sociologo licata 18
workshop stata sotto che non sono anche
casi stiamo andando gli orchi occhio o
occhialino chiodi vai vai ma da occhio
ai cori cori con i giorni con ricordi
fuori fuori fuori fuori fuori e come
l'aiuto io sono morto non lo so ci corro
io e tranquillo già fatta ma come e
fatta cadere da solo ma che succede
negli anni dato vita non so cosa che di
qua o là di nissim a calci un chiodo li
veloce by affetto occhio ecologia e ma è
spaccare ho mai licenziato già due volte
che ancora non sono morto mentre di
novara che ha colpito è capito che sto
facendo robin tax
ok
potevi inchiodare brocco arrivo ad avere
mai abbiamo fatto pochi occhio però c'è
un ma mia
ma dai e ti beccano un sacco di pioggia
aspettavano ben 800 gradi
ok a me ma backup sono how the vicenda
perché questo però linea destra bravo
già arrivati
non so come de vinco la parte lesa dopo
è la madonna
era una cassetta degli attrezzi vietato
ho mai fatti mai sparagli i fortissimi
in basso a sinistra non sono tutti i
libri con i lucchetti a non rigida libro
o credo che tu debba fare la maggior
parte delle cose qua e là anche dall'ok
venire anche da emma che vorrete un paio
e non lo senti odio che porti ad una
parte importante allarmate solo senso
l'infanzia tra mica il braccio di
vinchio dal libro io vado si capitolo
dolente di proprio ora che largo
inchiodano chiodo anche quelli anche
quelli vai bravo fabbro è fatta più
dello smarter mariscotti lo spaccati
tutte e due no a uno solo porco demonio
ecco mercato hanno spaccato un oratore
acquistato e il cavola doblò è la
madonna e basta che l'inizio di braccio
di come ci vado
la donna dai no no ragazzi facendo di
buchi occhio e carina il buco no l'ho
detto io e sono caduto
ok affinché la gli piacciono lo dirà
adesso dire la sicuro ecco lo inchioda
gliela poi è bravo i cavetti tosi e il
calo di chiaro bravo anche cosi vai
facciamo fatto lo stesso ma sta un po è
protetto mi sono fidato del mio salto in
avanti e che vuoi
aiutato da una botta e va beh sono
fortissimo le sue avengers a quello di
udine abbiamo spaccato sulla testa però
si spara di lì non chiedermi cosa fa ma
ciò che serve è infatti sul mare di
subito aiuto mi ha spaccato un punto
no toglierlo your smart town non si
scoraggia adesso a dubai somma ai avesse
dato pareri
vai il proprio va bene
no non è vero sei morto tu ti sei fatta
mai banali ma poi cosa è successo c'era
stato un bye dalla mia visione ho visto
un bug può rimanere the rimasto fermo
sulla piattaforma permette perché c'è
perché aerei appena sfornato un bella
carica formale meno ma meno male avrebbe
da dire hai fatto fuori ci ho creduto
veramente questi story oltretutto si
anima a questa scena un po fuorviante un
po brutto bene arie posso andare io non
so non ho fatto niente aiuto ma vuoti o
ratchet e clank pro lo ricordi il cescat
ok no bellissimo capito è proprio si si
si assumerà in poli sulle cose non è che
ci va aiutato no sono morto
ricucito a morire noi siamo andati 101
da falegnameria per forza ed è un casino
tra l'altro perché molto riuscendo a
farcela ce l'ha fatta
non so neanche dove cacchio ok che devo
fà ok se questo qua ok magari fatto mai
parlo di prima di questo qua
vai se ancora guardano è più veloce
cacciato ok è nato qui troppo ritardo
ritardino ai devo correre con triangolo
che se no c'ho fatto ci ha fatto ci ha
fatto già fatto perché mi era più lungo
capito grazie quanto già fatta bravo
lorenzo serie ma se ciao va benissimo è
stata geniale ma è che stiamo vivendo ha
schiacciato per vivere tosto sbagliata e
cioè uno peschici avere due da cagare
ecco perché non si attaccavano per forza
che è successo ok ok tu sia su quello di
nokia è vivo il vino come si potrebbe
chiamare siamo usciti finalmente fuori
da quel posto annunciato devo ricordarvi
che r b e un altro caso è quello che
penso io è un altro di montegrosso io
guardo sempre due boe poi poi sono un
sacco di formiche cioè un po di roberto
cravero quello di roberto parità ghetto
a 0 dalla roma non dobbiamo collaborare
qua ci possiamo andare per i carc i
nostri cioè per niente andiamo nella
stessa strada pianto cacchio il grosso
sto albero
è questo che anch'io vorrei giocarci
tanti ci sta a fare ancora un po basso
blog ti fanno amare il fatto di essere
un fatto è certo cos'è sta roba è un
albero un attimo ha capito le ragioni di
buono era chiusa fine è strano che a
parte fatto che non ci arriva mai è una
cosa enorme ma è infatti ma che è la
casa o una cosa nell'albero vedi lo
sapevo io a 200 fra qaida non è suo
fratello
no no ci hanno intrappolato è adesso
dobbiamo uscire ma è fanta che si è una
stanza dell'interrogatorio
ecco a noi esponiamo non ci possono fare
fuori per sempre perché l'espone all
ascom yapi sono su un topo ma infatti
che cosa ha fatto tutto io
la ferita di guerra infatti quale blu o
no salvate lo scoiattolo ryan la spara
linee uguale ebbe allora come importa
c'erano del genere ti ricordi che
starebbe per dare ma perché io voglio
questo grazie ciao ciao ciccio sono
proprio per quanto bello errori con
quella spalamento
[Musica]